[Music]
you guys hear that
i know that song
it's coming from my room
i'm going to get dr reyes don't
no no i buried this
we are going to tell you about our new
movie the new mutants in just
60 seconds ready go i play danny a young
mutant who wakes up in a sketchy medical
facility run by dr reyes you're not
alone danny danny meets the other young
mutants being monitored there
rayne ileana roberto and sam dr reyes
wants to help them understand their new
powers so they have therapy sessions to
discuss their haunted past
what if i just want to go home sam you
remember what happened
yep therapy
but then things get weird
and they discover that they can't leave
this isn't a hospital
it's a cage as if being trapped in a
creepy hospital isn't horrifying enough
they have to face their fear when a
sinister force invades
they start to question dr reed's motives
you can't live when i say so we're
trapped in here with demons and you want
us to stay trapped
it only gets worse from there
do they get answers go see the new
mutants to find out
get tickets now
[Music]
you